so we've talked a lot on the show about
the scaling up of the trade war with
China that Donald Trump has waged which
has actually increased our trade deficit
with them even though Donald Trump said
he was going to get rid of that trade
deficit and end up with a trade surplus
with China hasn't happened the wacky
tariffs have actually made it even worse
so that's China and we've talked about
that but today I want to talk about the
trade war with Europe at least to get us
into a more general conversation about
tariffs and this is a bigger fight than
just related to Donald Trump this is
part of the Airbus versus Boeing fight
that exists Boeing of course the
us-based airline airplane manufacturer
and Airbus is a European aircraft
manufacturer and Donald Trump is
complaining about European subsidies on
Airbus recently tweeting quote the World
Trade Organization finds that the
European Union subsidies to Airbus has
adversely impacted the United States
which will now put tariffs on 11 billion
dollars of EU products the EU has taken
advantage of the US on trade for many
years it will soon stop so what Donald
Trump is going to do is find 11 billion
dollars in European goods to slap some
tariffs on - and the problem of course
like with many of these tariff ideas
that Donald Trump has and sometimes puts
into into action the problem is that
it's not going to solve the Boeing
Airbus issue which supposedly is what
Donald Trump is concerned with it's just
going to make Americans have to pay more
for European stuff and the other sort of
weird thing about this is that the World
Trade Organization already ruled that
Europe subsidies on Airbus were illegal
back in May of 2018 and at the same time
the United States also subsidizes Boeing
and Europe is preparing a list of
American products to put tariffs on - to
punish us for our subsidies on Boeing
and you can very quickly see how this is
an escalation of tension with our
supposed allies in a way that's not
going to achieve what Donald Trump
claims he wants to achieve on trade and
that's a really important thing when we
analyze the effect of these polit
policies and tariffs we can analyze them
generally for the record
compact but we also have to compare them
with Donald Trump stated goals for
putting them in and one of those goals
with China for example was to reduce the
trade deficit and in fact his policy
with China on trade and tariffs has done
the opposite we have a record-high trade
deficit with China and what we're doing
in practice is sort of retaliating
against admittedly bad economics with
more bad economics and Trump repeats
this over and over again while claiming
that he's the only guy who can fix it
and if you have like even the most basic
understanding of basic economics and
globalization you would then be in a
position to realize why this is the
political equivalent of a penis size
contest but where you're not even really
sure what the penis is like you've got
someone comparing the size of their
penis to someone else's thumb right like
I it's kind of a cartoonish analogy but
it's you take a penis size contest which
in and of itself is not a particularly
useful thing and then you realize
someone is not even actually looking at
the size of their penis in the
comparison so to speak if people knew
more about economics and trade they
might never have fallen for Trump's
bogus promises during the campaign to
begin with about how he's gonna fix
NAFTA and he's going to fix China and
all of this stuff but his base fell very
hard for it and now Trump is making the
problems even worse and there are some
reasonable arguments to be made for
tariffs in certain situations but there
are some fundamental truths about how
tariffs work that are completely missing
here number one trade wars aren't easy
to win as Donald Trump likes to claim
they're easy to start they're easy to
escalate they're easy to get completely
stuck in and extend but there's a point
that's missing which is that when you
put tariffs on European or Chinese goods
it's really a tax on Americans and what
I mean by that is that when you tariff a
foreign good you're effectively adding a
tax on Americans whether it's American
individuals or companies when they buy
that foreign good so it doesn't bring
jobs back to the United States it
doesn't create jobs it doesn't decrease
the trade deficit as Donnell
Trump promised it makes it grow actually
and at a larger level these trade wars
create uncertainty which is rarely good
for world markets it's rarely good for
domestic markets and in particular if
you see a world economic power like the
United States and you see them as a
potentially bad partner or as an
unreliable partner in trade it's not
good and that is sort of the the epitome
of what we are seeing here in Trump's
uninformed trade policy and most
disturbingly he continues to have his
base tricked into believing he
understands this stuff and he's doing
the right thing and it is imploding in
front of our very eyes every single week
and this 11 billion is just going to
make it even worse